che succede
vediamo
nuovissimo gioco nuovissima storia non
so se vi ricordate una volta siamo
andati a trovare la nonna cattiva e
guarda vieni qua nella prima macchina
presto sta per partire presto sbagliato
dove sei lasciato c'è scritto no aspetta
Ma se non ti devo dire
parte Dai dai dai Sali sulla macchina
senta Ecco siamo tutti e due qua dietro
quanti posti c'ha questa macchina è tipo
un pulmino per portarci tutti dall'anno
Ok Google
Siamo andati a trovare la nonna ma poi
si rivelava una trappola Insomma se non
l'avete visto andate a vederlo vi lascio
poi la casellina dopo questo video
questa volta c'è questo nuovo gioco in
cui andiamo a trovare il nonno però
nell'immagine di copertina c'era il
nonno con un mitragliatore
sordo Quindi non credo che sarà un nonno
molto amorevole che si preparano
Sì certo Ti piacerebbe no sì mi
piacerebbe non dire no no siamo partiti
Aspetta non ho capito Eccolo Oh vediamo
cosa è successo
Sono troppo curiosa ovviamente sarà una
storia paurosa Immagino Ok siamo con la
casa del nonno Siamo in tanti però così
sta arrivando e questo è il nonno
vediamo com'è non lo so Ehi c'è nessuno
è arrivato
Vi lascio qua così state per il weekend
a casa adesso tutto il weekend ci
divertiremo dico io eh Eh non lo so non
credo
bene assicurati di aver preso tutto e
Ciao Ok va bene andiamo a prendere tutto
da dietro Ah Qual è la mia valigia
perfetta
andiamo fino alla porta possiamo entrare
adesso dal nonno cattivo vediamo com'è
Chissà se come granny Eccolo lo vedete
è seduto lì sulla poltrona entra nella
sala da pranzo Mamma mia non ha un
bell'aspetto questo nonno chi siete ma
Ma che stai dicendo Ti sei rimbambito
mi saluti nipoti Ti ricordi
tocco cagnolino che carino Io non ho
nessun nipote molto bene
Non ti ricordi di noi tu giocavi a
baseball con noi ehm
non mi ricordo nessun gioco baseball
Andate via andate via ok Oh no Inizia
già male scappa Ok scappiamo scappiamo
perché non No dice scappa dal nonno
Bravo braccio
a terra aiuto
scappiamo Ehi
perché non lo so perché
devi dire Prego Aspetta ho trovato il
frigo ho trovato il frigo dobbiamo No no
no mi ha dato una bastonata No aiuto
finisce la vita e sarai fuori dal gioco
Sette non mi fa passare né dalle scale
ma lui è fermo lì in cucina Dai ok Uno
mo si addormenta e non lo so Uh stiamo
sopravvissuti Allora prima solo noi
siamo sopravvissuti Sì ottimo e adesso
che dobbiamo fare cagnolino proteggeti
proteggeci tu da questo nonno cattivo
Ehi evitandovi tu Eh buongiorno Ti sei
svegliato Ah forse ci ha riconosciuto Sì
sono io dico io cioè figo Sì mi
riconosce nonno
Oh Non ti avevo riconosciuto bambino
Vieni vieni Siediti e prendi della
limonata e poi abbiamo visto cosa c'era
scritto Va bene Sono d'accordo io
accendo la luce intanto
andiamo a prendere la limonata
Bevi della limonata dice eccola qui è
sul tavolo
se non facciamo velocemente le cose che
ci piace Sì perdiamoci
per dopo non si sa mai Metti Io si
arrabbia di nuovo bene i giovani ora ho
del lavoro da fare fuori ok
Hai bisogno di aiuto nonno
no è meglio non chiedergli aiuto no
credo che ce la faccio da solo ma
guardatevi in giro intorno nella casa e
dovreste trovare qualcosa
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere insomma
per stare qua per qualche giorno ok
Forse dobbiamo scegliere la camera
22 secondi per esplorare la casa bottoni
subito
dobbiamo trovare la via d'uscita da
questa casa
c'è una porta con la chiave con
lucchetto Ciao Luca
accendiamo le luci intanto che cosa c'è
il bagno oh fatto Abbiamo esplorato
quindi penso che dovremmo dormire lì
avete sentito questo rumore dico io
quale rumore
[Musica]
sembra che viene da da fuori da dove il
nonno sta lavorando no io non voglio
andare a controllare Vacci tu dovremmo
andare a controllare eh appena detto che
non ho capito no no no no non voglio
andare andiamo a controllare Uffa adesso
non ci insegue con il porcone sembra che
venga da lì no una trappola Anche
secondo me è una trappola perché abbiamo
dentro è una trappola andiamo dentro
dobbiamo per forza aprire una porta di
questa fattoria aiuto cosa troveremo
ci stanno aprendo Eccolo cioè nonno che
sta aggiustando il trattore forse che
faccia simpatica
è vicino a vicino dove
ho dimenticato Dov'è ha detto Lo
dobbiamo trovare ci abbiamo solo 20
secondi ho trovato
Grazie per avermelo preso
abbiamo calmato almeno nessun problema
ora possiamo andarcine
Ehi Potete aiutarmi a aggiustare il
trattore
ho già fatto la maggior parte del lavoro
ma mancano ancora delle cose che sono in
giro qua dentro Ok dobbiamo trovare le
cose del trattore Tu vai in casa e dormi
Sì dai almeno riusciremo a trovare
meglio le cose senza lui che ci guarda
abbiamo 30 secondi di tempo per
sistemare il trattore no 40 ok Ho preso
la ruota Ok
Preso Se non riusciamo a fare tutto in
tempo ci farà perdere il gioco quindi
Sbrigatevi
forse non lo so Non capisco
ragazzi
oh no non c'è niente qua sopra 16
secondi manca il posto del trattore il
sedile Eccolo l'hai trovato Sì Mettilo
dai
e io un po' di sonno dovremmo andare a
dormire Ok Anita andiamo a dormire
allora non mi fido di dormire a casa del
nonno
Ok quindi tornare in camera che è
successo Ok ci sta teletrasportando in
camera
ci sono tanti letti ma gli altri sono
tutti morti quindi ci vediamo domani
mattina siamo rimasti solo noi andiamo a
dormire Cosa succede le tre meno cinque
del mattino che è successo avete sentito
quel rumore Io non ho sentito niente
moto Sì sembra che venga da giù dal
logway
[Musica]
dobbiamo scappare dal nonno dove Dov'è
Madonna
ora dovremmo fare qualcosa
velocissimamente No niente Manco io
siamo nel siamo nella fattoria cosa è
successo cioè intrappolate qua dentro e
adesso non lo so non mi ricordo niente
eh nonno ci ha preso
Abbiamo trovato le chiavi vedi perché
siamo qua nella fattoria
Cerchiamo le chiavi dai qualcosa per
scappare Non so ma nonno è impazzito
dobbiamo trovare un modo di uscire da
qua guarda io qui ho trovato un
passaggio segreto davvero forse si può
scappare da qui o forse dobbiamo cercare
la chiave aveva una chiave che riusciva
a sbloccare qua Ok Cerchiamo la chiave
presso
perché è troppo che ci saranno i secondi
ci porta però ho trovato la chiave bravo
Ok adesso scappiamo da qui aspettate
adesso sì o no lui è qua fuori voleva
incendiare tutto
pensavate di riuscire a scappare eh Ora
faremo in modo più difficile che cos'è
quello Loggia fiaba
al femminile no ha messo google Fienile
dobbiamo scappare da qui dai conosco la
strada Anita conosco la strada Ok su
non mi fa andare avanti Uh dobbiamo
attraversare questo campo ok e da quale
parte
[Musica]
abbiamo bisogno attento ti fai male su
quel coso lì no
ok Ragazzi abbiamo dovuto rifare tutta
da capo lasciate un bel mi piace per
supportarci perché abbiamo dovuto rifare
tutto da capo e abbiamo anche speso di
robox per cominciare ma non ha
funzionato e ora siamo riprovando a fare
la fine questa volta dobbiamo riuscirci
dobbiamo riuscirci
il portone qui c'è il nonno con
concata gamba dobbiamo scappare OK
riproviamo Speriamo di riuscirci questa
volta portateci fortuna Tu rispondi lì
dobbiamo stare attenti a quei forconi là
fuori Sì andiamo a scappare dalla
finestra
Ok Presto
via via prima che esploda tutto tu di
qua di qua di qua sbrigati sbrigati Ok
siamo riusciti a saltare fuori dalla
finestra almeno siamo Salviamo il tempo
contato per
attraversare questa parte attento ai
furgoni Ok ok attentati
Ok ci sono finora tutto bene Adesso non
so come salire qua
no pure tu sei caduta Sì aspetta non mi
spingere Ma io mica ti spingo
No no
Ok ce l'ho fatta davvero
Ok io sono rinato Wow ce l'ho fatta
Credo
di sì sono qua oh no sono rimasti pochi
secondi No non ce l'hai fatta
[Musica]
potevi pensavi di riuscire a scapparmi
ora è veramente un po' di finire cosa ha
iniziato vuole schiacciarmi con il
trapano
Sì a me m'ha preso invece
adesso devi scappare veloce no no no da
quella parte dentro dove devo andare
ti ha schiacciato col trattore ragazzi è
la terza volta che riproviamo Lasciateci
un mi piace per portarci fortuna perché
non ne posso più devi ricominciare tutto
da capo Io spero di non ricadere qui nei
forconi non sono neanche riuscito a
passarla questa parte Dai questa volta
dobbiamo farcela attenzione ti consiglio
di non stare troppo vicino gli altri
giocatori attenti ai forconi Sì non
farti prendere ti ripeto
saluto anche tu sì è difficilissimo
saltare la sopra
attenta a non cadere per terra perché
diventa Super difficile
No ma perché l'hanno fatto così difeso i
fatti
ok Sono riuscita a salire qua
Ok tutti e due spadellati non ci credo
ragazzi è impossibile
che proviamo non ci siamo riusciti
Purtroppo questo Escape Room è un fail
Ma voi lasciate un bel mi piace e se
questo video raggiunge i 5.000 mi piace
riproviamo un'altra volta e speriamo che
riusciremo insomma a sopravvivere questa
volta E ora vi lasciamo qualcosa che
altrimenti qui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite eh Buona visione Ciao